So what I'm showing you here is all
the events that are within a single process. Like,
all these events are events within my process.
These events are within expedia's process. These events are
within Delta process. And I'm sure that most
of you have identified all these as events that
are connected by, the happened-before relationship and here
I'm showing you all the events that are connected
by the communication events. A is the message sending from
me to expedia. B is the receiver of the message.
Similarly, C to D and E to F, G to H, I to J, K to L, those are all
the communication events. All of them are connected by this
happened-before relationship. And if you look at this event m,
that's a concurrent event with respect to the events that
are happening on my process as well as the Delta process.
So those are the things that I've marked as concurrent
events. If you didn't get all of these right, that's okay.